so i have a question for the panel um
when do you so since we talked a little
bit about earlier about what i thought
was a good reason to break up a home
what do you guys think is a good reason
i'm just going around yeah mental abuse
physical abuse
um
not really adultery
yeah i say mental physical abuse mental
and physical abuse okay what about you
yeah i think um yeah dv
um any sort of abuse um
and i do think repeated adultery yeah
repeated adultery okay about the same
abuse um
anything that leaks into the child's
life
and therefore affects the child yeah
it's good enough reason for you to leave
mine is solely mental abuse but only
because i've seen the impacts it's had
on people around me
and
how it affects not only the child but
their interactions with other people
and potentially
the difficulties that they face finding
a new person as well so definitely
mental abuse
yeah i would say death
duh yeah until death do us
isn't that what we signed like isn't
that what we said when we was up there
like you know i mean it's like okay so
my it's very easy for men to be like you
physically i mean you mentally abuse me
like he mentally abused me
like women are the king of games bro
from the minute from the minute we
started this relationship he was
mentally abusing me so now now now we're
even um what girls do you deal with this
is why
i'm just no you've got bad experiences
don't don't get me wrong i'm the most
empathetic to men's issues i'm so
empathetic i'm on your side
but like sometimes like i i do think
there's some accountability on the guys
for the women that you pick i love black
women
what did you say i love black women
okay what does that affect what i got
i have to
coordinate around in and around black
women pearls
like with two different
kettles of fish
yeah highly likely
they're coming from a single parent
household themselves you're coming from
a double parent household who stayed
together who's shown the successful work
you're different like you're
like sometimes i look at you and think
how
is she is she a female like do you know
what i mean i think are you a female
like because
and in england or america or in the west
because that is just not a normal
mindset to have the one that you have
the one that i'm talking about in terms
of the girls that's the normal mindset
i'm the b-o-s-s you can't tell me
nothing you pay the rent you go on the
first date you still can't tell me
nothing in this yard
it's super it's super common but i'm
telling you i know a good amount of
girls that don't have that mindset
and i'm saying like there has to be i
i'm with it like i understand the
struggles you guys go through but there
has to be some accountability right for
the men too when it comes to the type of
girls you choose to deal with
because i'm a big believer like as a
girl
every situation i've been is my own damn
fault like i've been cheated on before
and that was my own fault because i
picked him like my fault so i just think
it really is because if i if that's who
i chose it's my fault and i'm just a big
believer in like the situations you
choose to put yourself in if you got two
children for two quote-unquote crazy
baby mamas
okay fine they're not crazy but if
you've got two children for
two women and it's not going the way
that you want it to go
um then i said and like pearl said maybe
look at the women you're choosing bro
it's not that it's not that it's not
going the way i want it to go i am
accommodating them they're not
accommodating me i'm accommodating them
what does that mean what do you mean
like from the okay
my seeds
is like your egg is irrelevant without
my seeds so we are we are making the kid
together
it's not
your baby
yes right but a lot of women come with
that mentality of it's my baby and it's
true you are the father of my baby
that's because they have the leverage
yeah in the court like the courts back
them on this yeah yeah but i mean in
terms of like the attitude so it's like
it's i'm it's my baby but you're the
father what i'm saying like you could
you could pick girls that don't have
this attitude
yeah
no no but i'm just i'm just being honest
like again like it's twice right you've
two like two baby moms with two
different kids that's two families that
aren't going to be together yeah and and
like it has to say something about your
ability to pick no because
because i'll tell you why
encounter how many how many friends how
many women leave amer um
relationships again what was this this
is 70 to 80 oh my gosh right no i'm not
so i'm not leaving the relationship
she's leaving the relationship were you
interested were you in a relationship
yes the second girl no
i don't even want to go into why it has
to okay
but again
first one i i'll give to you right first
like okay you had nothing to do with it
but you you it's like
what is the best predictor of future
behavior past behavior
there we go so i did not
i didn't agree to to have
intercourse with her
ah
what happened she took your spam no i
was i was drunk and i was sleeping and i
woke up with her on top okay jesus yeah
but you still got a
finish
yeah
that's why i take responsibility for it
but at the end of the day
you tell her to stop
hell no
listen no that's no
no you're sounding like they're women
okay you're drunk you're drunk and
you're sleeping and you wake up with me
in you
wait wait wait wait wait are we just
like no no no no we're not dating so bro
you've got an erection while you were
sleeping
would you meet a light you know have we
hooked up before
no
you've never hooked up with her no so
the first time you met this girl you
were drunk and then you she found
herself on top of you and then pregnant
and then you're pregnant same time
pretty much
stop the cap
no rule rubber rule stuff like i find it
i find it very embarrassing when you
woke up and then when you woke up and
she was on top of you you did not stop
you didn't say oh my god what you're
doing get off me you said actually keep
going and i'm gonna go till i finish no
i i said i was drunk
so i'm
okay
exactly but you're already on me and
it's i'm not gonna lie it's feeling good
you're you know what i'm trying to say
but it's now after i'm click like you
know i'm just gonna say i'm clicking in
now wait hold on a minute hold on hold
on like how did you like wait what
and it's like after but
it'd be tough for you to claim that that
happened purely because when
you had the opportunity to stop yeah you
did not
yeah but bro if if it was my choice i
would have put a condom on are you not
listening like
i'm not saying i'm not saying you it
wasn't your choice but i'm saying i'm
like i'm thinking of the equivalent
right if a guy i was seeing like that
happened to me right and i woke up and
then i was like oh yeah let's keep going
and then we finished then i say after oh
i was grape like i think a lot of people
would kind of look at me funny right you
know what i'm saying like if i if i got
on top and started riding right like
like and then people be like
how can you say you were graped if you
finished it that's why i didn't answer
when he said was i great because i like
okay i was vying i said sa though i was
right that's what i think it was it was
uh it was essay and it was it wasn't
great it was sa
but you enjoyed it
wait hold on you're drunk and i have sex
with you yeah just because you enjoy it
does that mean that you agree to it well
does she wake up and say stop like get
off me or does she say oh [ __ ] like and
then start riding like there's two
different there's two different no you
lot you look you lost him because if i
if a girl says she's drunk yeah and i
had and i had intercourse with her while
she was sleeping that's automatic me
cancelled bro why are you not even
trying to make excuses for the guy bro
like i don't get like if she did that to
me like if i'm drunk enough if you said
stop and you would like oh [ __ ] like
what are you doing like i didn't say
what you're doing i didn't say it stop
i'm like we do we doing and then what
what do you mean brother no it's like
i'm drunk and you're on me riding bro
like i like you
but i would keep it the same with a girl
like i would keep it the same with a
girl if she was seeing a dude and she
was in a situation when they're in bed
together so i'm assuming there's some
history and she wakes up and he he's in
her and if she says what the like get
off of me that's one thing but if if she
finishes like then
how am i going to say that's not
consensual yeah yeah but then there's no
one witnessing it so they can easily
turn that around if they regret
afterwards that's the thing that women
do yeah i mean don't give me there's a
lot of issues in the justice system like
that definitely favor
women but i'm saying i'm keeping a stack
with you i would keep it the same a man
or a woman
so you're saying
that if i went
took like we had like drinks or whatever
we're chilling and we go back to mine
and you fall to sleep
and you wake up with me on top of you
pearl
you're like your first fool as a woman
anyway is like raw what are you doing
right but you're talking about a man now
sarah you kind of bro i'm not saying she
was butters i didn't say she was not
were you planning to do it
no otherwise i was planning to have sex
with her but not without a condom on
right okay do you understand what i'm
trying to say like yeah she's nice and
whatever but i wanted to have sex with a
condom on because of my previous no
reactions though you consented because
you didn't tell it to stop exactly
so now i'm drunk now
if i was in my head level-headed i would
have said get off because when i when i
did come around to my head i'm like what
the hell like what do you do we tell
women the same thing right we say listen
if you go if you go back to a guy's
place right and your intention is to
have sex right
and
it happens and then after the fact now
you're saying all of these things people
speculate as to what really happened and
that
is that really happened why did you go
back to his place like what were you
doing on the bed of him what if he
didn't want to do it why are you we
speculate and that's all we're doing
with you this is because it just sounds
a little bit sketchy bro that's all no i
it's not sketchy bro she i i didn't mind
having sex with her but you just didn't
want to do it with a condom right and i
didn't know you could have stopped her
before it was time to finish no you see
this is this is this is the gray area
now so now this is the gray area i'm
drunk i can't i'm not in control
i'm not in control just like how women
say i'm not in control i'm not in
control because i'm not in my right
state of mind so whether or not i decide
whether or not i want to have all right
all right
when i talk to girl like i say the same
thing right i say if i get drunk and rob
a store i'm still liable for robbing
that store if i get drunk and have sex
like i'm not going to put that on the
guy
personally i know some girls do but this
is just i'm just keeping it
drinking asleep how long between you
waiting to get it up yeah how long
between you waking up realizing oh [ __ ]
she's on me
to you finishing not very long
oh so it was oh my god
oh my god well not really it was it was
like i would say give it 20 30 seconds
bro i'm not in my right state of mind
that i'm not like pre i don't like
coming for
i'm not
i'm not one minute man but if i'm not
prepared if i'm not in my like frame to
hold it out like and i'm drunk i'm not
like you know i'm gonna say bro i'm even
back the day after i'm like did that
even happen bro you know you don't
understand how drunk i was bro like i
don't like eat
okay i'm not saying